hey youtubers what's up so there's a
brand new age of Ultron trailer dropping
tonight so I wanted to do a video for my
top five Ultron stories in the comics
they're making some key changes to the
vision and Ultron in the movie but i'll
talk more about that during my trailer
video this is all about the comics so
just to start off my list let's say
number five the first appearance of
ultron in the comics in case you haven't
read any the old avengers comics the
character was created by roy thomas back
in 1968 the core concept in the design
of the character were actually inspired
by the living robot character called
Makino from this saturday morning cereal
in the 1950s called captain video i just
i love the idea that saturday morning
cartoons inspired the creation of ultron
George Lucas on in another example
borrowed a lot from the Flash Gordon
cereals in the 1950s whenever he wrote
start wars so it just melts your pop
culture brain so Ultron's first
appearance was in Avengers number 54
that was just a cameo though it was just
like a WTF reveal it was part of this
weird Masters of evil story where Ultron
secretly hypnotizes Edwin Jarvis the the
jars that were actually seeing on agent
Carter right now this guy he hypnotizes
Jarvis into hiring the Masters of evil
to take down the Avengers already this
is super complicated and you can see how
there's no way they would do this in the
movie but it gets really awesome when
you think about the fact that Paul
Bettany is becoming the vision in the
way that plays out with the way Edwin
Jarvis was using this original story
even cooler that original ultron story
featured Black Panther and did this big
flashback scene where Ulysses Klaw talks
about how he tried to steal all of what
conda's vibranium I know there are a lot
of people that just think that Andy
Serkis is playing that character in the
movie and they'll use it to like
groundwork for Black Panther and civil
war so even though the movie is taking
from a different Avengers story and
modifying that as well quite a bit you
can see how there's like a lot of DNA
from the original Ultron story so just
look for lots of easter eggs from this
very first Ultron story whenever you do
see the movie it was until a couple
issues later and Avengers 58 that they
told the story of how Hank Pym created
Ultron using his own brain waves as a
template Ultron develops the oedipal
complex thinks of him as his father
falls in love with Janet Van Dyne the
boss in the rest is history it was a
little confusing the first time he
showed up because he was Ultron version
5 and everyone was like WTF happened to
the other four versions again you know
so
tweeks happening to that in the movie
but i'll explain in my trailer video
tonight Ultron is like this evolving
hyper mind with the emotional fortitude
of an emo teenager which of course by
default makes him everyone's worst
nightmare nothing worse than an emo
teenager on to number four the first
appearance of the Silver Age vision so
the original version of the vision the
golden age version is an alien from an
alternate dimension during the 1960's
Stanley decided he wanted an Android
character to join The Avengers he and
the other writers repurposed the vision
character and turned him into the
Android vision so most of the time
whenever people talk about the vision in
the context of the Marvel Universe
they're talking about the Silver Age
vision the second version he appeared
for the first time in 1968 in Avengers
number 57 the core of the story is all
about vision being more of a synthetic
human than an Android is part of the
characters journey that he endeavors to
be more human it's like data on Star
Trek next gen there Pinocchio characters
which makes you think even more about
the strings line from that first trailer
and Ultron being this dark version of
Pinocchio no more strings on me so the
Avengers learned that Ultron 5 creates
vision to infiltrate the team and
destroy them but he made vision so
perfectly that he begins to feel
emotions develops a conscience and turns
against Ultron if any of you are
breaking bad fans or Watchmen fans at
the end of the story after a vision in
the Avengers defeat Ultron Stanley wrote
in the Ozymandias poem as an epilogue it
is just this poem about a traveler who
goes to Egypt and sees this inscription
written by an ancient king the
inscription basically says look at how
awesome I am look at this giant Empire I
built but the traveler can only see just
miles and miles of sand in every
direction it's just that the empire that
the king claimed to have belted crumbled
to dust then it was all meaningless at
this point so in the context of the
Avengers story Ultron is the ancient
king if you think about it in the
context of the movies Tony Stark kind of
starts out being the Ozymandias
character and Ultron played by James
Spader's trying to crush everything he
built I guess until the Paul Bettany
vision comes along and crushes Ultron's
Empire of replicants so I guess at the
end of the day the movie version of
Ultron is still Ozymandias I feel like
everyone's going to rush to Netflix
tonight to look for that breaking bad
ozymandias episode is actually really
good so like way later in the comics in
Avengers 93 there's this journey to the
center of the earth type story where
aunt
and shrinks down goes inside visions
body to examine them and then it kind of
lays the teaser for them finding out
that vision was created from the
original human torch but that story
didn't really play out till Avengers 134
I'll be really interested to see the way
the movie plays with that like you have
the vision being created from the bones
of another character on to number three
we stand at Armageddon this was Avengers
number 66 through 68 it was the
introduction of adamantium in the Marvel
Universe the vision under control of
Ultron tries to steal adamantium from
the Avengers so that he can upgrade his
body and become indestructible there's
the scientist named iron McLain he
accidentally invents it while trying to
create a new indestructible alloy for
the US military Wakanda trying to be
helpful gives him like a small portion
of vibranium and as a result of a lot of
tinkering adamantium is born but the
writers of the comic made it so that the
scientists didn't fully understand what
was going on so it was built as an
accident I think that was just to keep
the Avengers from getting overpowered I
mean if you can make an unlimited supply
of adamantium why not just use it to
make everything that needs metal like
adamantium cars adamantium refrigerator
adamantium spoons obviously because of
the rights issues the Marvel movies have
stuck with vibranium as it's only super
strong metal so I'm interested to see
how Ultron seeks out more vibranium to
build his final body from on to number
two Ultron unlimited so this is from the
1998 Avengers run number 19 to 22 by
kurt busiek it was really dark Ultron
takes over the Western European country
of slow Renia turns everyone into robot
clones essentially killing everyone and
it becomes this robot Hitler story of
how he takes over the country so this
took Ultron to this really crazy place
instead of just threatening genocide he
actually goes through with it and Hank
Pym his creator has to live knowing that
his creation killed an entire country
worth of people so essentially Hank Pym
has all this blood on his hands so look
at this panel right here doesn't this
kind of look familiar this is the promo
art for the movie in the country that
the Avengers are going to in the movie
is called sokovia sounds a lot like
selanne in the comic book story so you
can see where they sync up and my number
one Ultron story annihilation conquest
this dovetails with the Ultron
initiative storyline so I'm just going
to mention them both just because one
leads right into the
in the wake of Civil War Iron Man kind
of as a character came off as a bad guy
so to make him more sympathetic bendis
had Ultron infect Tony Stark's extremist
armor because extremist is bonded with
his DNA Ultron essentially takes control
of Tony Stark and goes on to create a
new body that ends up looking just like
Janet Van Dyne albeit with metal skin
and really creepy eventually Aries
defeats Ultron shoots his disembodied
consciousness into deep space then
during the annihilation conquest story
line when that picks up Ultron finds the
Phalanx becomes their new God and then
uses them to try and conquer the galaxy
so that conflict is really important not
only because it was a big comic book
storyline but it's the call to action
that creates the guardians of the galaxy
team the current team that you see in
the movies right now so Ultron I mean
just in the comics is responsible for
the creation of guardians of the galaxy
obviously the movie twisted that a
little bit but it's totally possible
that at the end of Avengers 2 they could
shoot Ultron into deep space and he
shows up as the main villain in
guardians of the galaxy two I think I
think we'd have to ask james gunn about
that i think he's got a short list of
candidates for main villains in the
movie really I'm not expecting it to
happen but it is possible if he wants to
go with something straight out of the
comics so here's my big question for you
guys what is your favorite Ultron story
from the comics and which ones do you
think they can realistically do in a
future movie right now to me it's
feeling like Ultron's gonna be a red
skull type villain someone's who's you
know really big but who only shows up
like once every six or seven years like
I'm not expecting to see him in Avengers
3 I think what they know what they might
do in that movie is have fanno sleeting
an army of crea or something similar
some other galactic race that's not
controlled by fox or Sony but in related
news important stuff tonight New
Avengers trailer be sure to subscribe to
get it i'll post the video right after
it drops online fingers crossed we get a
good look at the vision but that's kind
of a long shot right now you can
actually click here to get that trailer
video all of the annotation as soon as I
post it tonight and you can click here
to catch up on agent Carter new episode
of that tomorrow so thank you so much
for watching everybody high five I'll
see you tonight
you